bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler des
troubadours encore un épisode pour lé
nord formidable ben je te rappelle que
chez médiéviste à la base alors non je
parle pas trop de temps et donc désolé
je maîtrise pas assez le sujet tout ça
c'est bien
c'est quoi un troubadour vraiment des
poètes qui sont un peu devenu un
archétype du moyen âge on emprunte dans
toutes les fêtes médiévales même s'il
parle pas un mot d'occitan connais pas
les trouvères alors ça te dit quelque
chose
ah ouais moi y en avait déjà plus à mon
époque quand mais je connais café on va
parler des deux
[Musique]
les troubadours sont souvent vus comme
de pauvres chanteur alors de château en
château pour exercer leur art et la
plupart des chants médiévaux leur sont
associés alors qu'en réalité pas du tout
les troubadours ne représente qu'un
mouvement politique temporaire de la fin
du xième à la fin du xiiie siècle est
localisée la poésie des troubadours naît
à la fin du xième siècle à la cour de
poitiers le premier troubadour connu
étant guillaume 9 duc d'aquitaine
pas vraiment un loisir de décor donc
durant sa jeunesse il a étudié la
musique dans les écoles épiscopale et il
s'inspire des hymnes et liturgique et de
la poésie latine et arabes pour composer
des vers qui il chante lui même ne
parlons pas l'occitan je ne vais pas
vous faire l'affront de réciter un
extrait mais c'était plutôt joli
voyez plutôt je peux chanter si vous
voulez non non de sa cour l'art des
troubadours se répand en aquitaine dans
les moulins et en provence soit dans
toutes les régions de languedoc puisque
c'était la langue dans laquelle sont
rédigées ces poèmes le mot troubadours
vient de l'occitan trobar qui signifie
trouver poétiser les premiers
troubadours sont souvent de grands
seigneurs comme jaufré rudel ou quatre
ans de bornes ou de petits chevaliers
comme rimbaud de vacqueyras on compte
aussi une vingtaine de femmes tropez
rites comme la comtesse béatrice de 10
ou à salaise de porc caraquet en tout on
compte 460 troubadours entre 1100 et
1200 80 dont une centaine nous est
connue grâce au vide des biographies de
troubadours souvent posthume est donc
assez romance et en dehors des grands
seigneurs qui composent pour le plaisir
la plupart des troubadours sont des
courtisans qui dépendent du mécénat de
leur seigneur pour vivre certaines cours
deviennent des centres culturels
importants comme celles d'el de de
ventadorn qui crée une école de l'art
poétique dans sa seigneurie du limousin
devenir le protecteur de trop bateau est
un signe de réussite et de goût leur
présence est prétexte à l'organisation
de fêtes destiné à impressionner
l'aristocratie locale la renommée des
troubadours va de pair avec l'émergence
d'un nouvel art de vivre dans les cours
du début du 2ème siècle qui met en avant
le faste et la courtoisie des notions
chanter est véhiculée par les
troubadours
parmi les cours les plus en vogue celle
d'aliénor d'aquitaine petite fille du
premier troubadour guillaume 9
d'aquitaine contribuer à 10
l'art du trop bas au delà des terres du
midi en effet elle épouse d'abord le roi
de france louis 7 puis le roi
d'angleterre henri plantagenêt et reçoit
des troubadours dans toutes les cours où
elle s'installe elle transmet sa passion
à ses enfants qui épouse à leur tour
plein de gens importants un peu partout
en europe et ça fait d'être au batteur
bref on a vu comment les troubadours
apparaissent mais que font-ils de leur
journée finalement la poésie des
troubadours repose avant tout sur la
fin'amor l'amour courtois en langue
d'oil c'est un art d'aimer qui repose
sur la joie la patience et la mesure par
exemple certains troubadours amoureux de
dame de la noblesse compose pour elle
des champs dans lesquels les anonymise
leurs noms ou vous même jusqu'à oser un
peu d'érotisme qui prend la forme d'un
baiser ou du don d'un anneau ça reste
plutôt soft sonné le glas a sonné le
départ de l'onuci je vous le donne
non la fin'amor c'est avant tout une
exaltation de l'esprit on évite de
parler de nudité ou d'adultère réel
d'abord poésie elle devient un art de
vivre commenté à la cour et faisant
l'objet de débats en 1185 andré le
chapelain rédige de l'arn est d'aimer et
de la réprobation de l'amour dans lequel
il déclare le vrai amour est toujours
timide il ne dort ni ne mangent celui
que passion d'amour tournante n'est ce
pas aliénor retrouverait amour était
plutôt timide mais je pouvais pas savoir
que sir gow3 on reste concentrés poésie
des troubadours peut prendre plusieurs
formes toutes très codifié les comme
sonne par exemple sont des chansons
d'amour accompagné d'une mélodie les
cires vente' ce sont des chants
satirique politique ou moraux qui
s'inspire des moeurs et de l'actualité
de l'époque père cardinal par exemple
raconte dans sa vie d'à qu'il composa
marc cervantes ou il blâme et fort les
folies de ce monde la corruption du
clergé et les vices de la noblesse ou
les lacie la décadence le plan déplore
la mort d'un grand personnage ou d'une
amante l'alba annonce la séparation de
deux amants au lever du jour
la balade est faite pour danser les
pastourelles sont des pièces rustique
dans lesquelles un chevalier séduit une
bergère quelle faute de goût et alors
attendez que deux troubadours se
rencontrent il se lance alors dans des
défis poétique
layton ou jacques partie des joutes
verbales où ils doivent chacun en
musique défendre leurs arguments sur un
sujet choisi à la fin du xiiie siècle
l'art des troubadours des
les croisade contre les cathares en
terre d'oc et l'arrivée de l'inquisition
modifie les moeurs de la société
courtoise les chansons d'amour
disparaissent au profit de chansons
mariale religieuse et l'amour courtois
devient beaucoup trop subversif pour
être chantée les derniers troubadour
dans les années 1990 s'installe en
aragon en pastilles en italie pour y
continuer leur art mais la fin des
troubadours ne signifie pas la fin de la
poésie dès le second tiers du deuxième
siècle on rencontre des troubadours dans
certaines cours du nord josé par exemple
parler de celle d'aliénor d'aquitaine en
france puis en angleterre la culture
chevaleresque et courtoise se répandent
dans les cours de flandre de champagne
de picardie d'artois et donne naissance
à de nouveaux poètes les trouvères
littéralement l'équivalent en languedoc
des troubadours trobar trouvèrent comme
des troubadours beaucoup de trous verts
sont issus de la noblesse ou sont des
courtisans on peut citer parmi les
premiers chrétiens 2,3 et un doazit gaz
brûlés
la mode des trouvères se répand en
bretagne avec les bretons à la fin du
12e siècle et même en allemagne avec les
1900 guerre à partir du xiiie siècle la
bourgeoisie de flandre et d'artois se
prend au jeu et donne un nouvel élan à
la poésie d'être ouvert leur style de
chant s'inspire de celui des troubadours
le grand champ pour l'attentât loeb pour
l'alba et le servant toit pour le
cervantes la pastourelle est aussi très
répandu ainsi que de nouveaux champs qui
leur sont propres la reverdie est un
champ de printemps la chanson de toile
un petit drame d'amour la route rue ange
un champ à refrain le mot tu es une
polyphonie vocale la fatrasie joue
surtout avec les mots les congés sont
des poèmes d'adieu de l'épreuve à leur
ville natale
les chansons de croisades sont sur des
gens qui partent en croisade les
trouvères et tampons beaucoup des
bourgeois des villes à la fin du xiiie
siècle et s'organisent en confréries
comme n'importe quel corps de métier la
ville d'arras par exemple compte environ
80 poète dont le seigneur rue d'arras
himself des confréries organise des
concours poétique les puits dans
lesquelles les gagnants sont nommés
prince au roi le plus ancien concours et
le puits vers d'arras fondée en 1194 est
le plus grand gagnant et jehan braudel
qui participent à 99 puis et en est
régulièrement nommé prince au 14e siècle
guillaume de machaut l'un des derniers
trouvères connu
rédige 235 balade 21 rondeau 33 virolet
la première messe à quatre voies est une
oeuvre en associant plus
systématiquement la musique à sa poésie
parce que les troubadours être ouverts
ne déclame et pas forcément eux mêmes
leurs verres et ne jouais pas forcément
d'un instrument pour cela il se faisait
accompagné de musiciens chanteurs ap les
ménestrels de jongleurs chaque
troubadours à un ou plusieurs ménestrel
à son service ils doivent savoir rim est
parlée chantée lire à voix haute joux
est de -9 instruments de musique faire
des acrobaties imiter le chant des
oiseaux
d'autres ménestrel ne sont pas attachés
à un troubadour ou un trouvère mais sont
au service d'un prince et l'accompagnent
dans tous ses déplacements
tant et si bien rodé alors la personne
ce qui fait que tomber tout le monde
s'en fout ce métier se retrouve aussi
dans les foires et des villes mais on
les appelle alors battle heures histrion
au 14e siècle
les ménestrels se rassemblant
corporation sous l'autorité d'un roi des
ménestrels la plus vieille corporation
est celle de paris créé en 1321 qui fixe
la durée d'apprentissage des jeunes
ménestrel à 6 ans les corporations de
ménestrels organisent leurs propres
concours lyrique et ont quelques
privilèges comme le droit de traverser
le petit pont de paris contre une
chanson et tu chantes s'est payé non
mais tu pourra traverser un pont ce sera
super pour ta visibilité hockey de tous
les poèmes déclamés par les troubadours
environ 2500 demeure mis par écrit entre
20 et 100 ans après leurs compositions
les trouvères pour leur part nous ont
laissé environ 2500 m et 4 mai mélodies
le rythme et le détail de
l'accompagnement musical par contre ne
nous sont pas parvenus j'espère que cet
épisode vous a plu si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur les troubadours le
trouvère les ménestrels vous pouvez
consulter le livre la vie quotidienne au
moyenne d'âge écrit par justin de france
c'est moi et puis vous avez aussi toute
la biographie que je mettrai dans la
description comme d'habitude
et puisqu'on est dans les trucs fait par
mois on peut dire que les trouvères est
trop bas d'orfraie du divertissement
comme moi avaient classés
de taille noir qui est en cours de
financement participatif actuellement un
peu parler de cette série dans laquelle
mon visage est totalement transfiguré je
n'approuve pas donc si vous avez aimé la
saison une si vous aimez l histoire les
voyages dans le temps l'humour les trucs
fait par mois vous pouvez consulter le
lien url qui s'affiche ici et que vous
retrouverez aussi en descriptions le
partager et mamie faire un don si vous
le souhaitez ça nous aiderait grandement
vous seriez alors tels les seigneurs
mécène des arts d'antan et ça c'est
classe en attendant à bientôt pour un
nouvel épisode de gentes dames badass
portez vous bien
d'où ce fameux volet pour deux postes
mais connu les signaux les seuls mots
fort leveau seulement
mais vous savez tri mais c'est mon coup
elle ces deux mots qu'est le conflit et
au labour day le mot
kima de rien envie
fort des travaux bailly et ceux des
autres et pourquoi l'érigent morts tout
ça me joly pour deux pense à semer tenu
à signaler
sale gosse fauveau seulement